failure on the path of success a lot of
times we look at successful people we
look at people who we look up to who we
want to be like and we look at their
story and what do we see all we see is
how easy it was for them we look at
their big wins we look at what made them
successful say I want to be like that
but what you don't see is how hard it
was for them how many failures they had
along their way and why that's so
important is because every successful
person failed along the way to becoming
successful they failed they failed they
failed multiple times before they hit it
big and the ones who made it were the
ones who stuck through who adapted who
changed that's what helped make them
successful and this is so important
because for too many people most people
are stuck in that zone of failure you
might be stuck you're trying things and
not seeing any momentum not seen any
money coming in not seeing anything
happened nobody believes in what you're
doing you're all alone and you say what
wins at my turn what do I get to be like
that person it was so easy for that why
am i struggling so much it wasn't easy
for them they had just as hard a time as
you're having right now the only
difference is they stuck with it one of
my favorite stories is of Baskin Robbins
started by two brothers in law's one
name Basques one name Robbins they had a
vision for a world that had different
ice cream flavors they wanted to start
an ice cream shop that didn't just sell
chocolate and vanilla and sometimes
strawberry they wanted unique flavors
this was their big idea is what they're
gonna hit it big with and yet not all
the flavors took off they had lots of
failures auction this thing they came up
with ketchup ice cream that didn't work
they had bagels and lox ice cream that
didn't work they had Great Britain Great
Britain ice cream that didn't work they
launched one ice cream called gummy
gummy gummy ops where they put gumdrops
in two vanilla ice cream and frozen and
the gumdrops in the frozen state became
so hard that they're aware that would
break people's teeth off they had the
puller from the stores
they could have looked that those
failures and said you know what this
this isn't worth it
this isn't gonna work but they found
another way to stand they kept going
they changed their products around and
they built an empire they built the most
successful ice cream franchise company
in the world too many people are stuck
with their ketchup ice cream and they
don't change you're stuck in your
failure zone because you're selling
ketchup ice cream and you're not
adapting if you want to have success if
you want to be like Baskin Robbins if
you want to achieve your dreams you want
to get out there and be something then
you have to realize that you're gonna
fail along the way and the difference
between the ones who make it and the
ones who don't the people who get their
dreams come true and the ones who don't
who sit there and keep wondering why me
why is this not happening is the
difference is because you kept going you
kept trying you kept changing you kept
adapting the idea that you start with is
never the idea that hits it big you look
at companies like BMW they started in
airplanes what do you think their logo
is propeller they started selling
airplanes but what helped them hit it
biggest cars the idea that you start
with is almost never the idea that helps
make you big you've got to adapt and
change and if you're stuck in that
failure zone it's just a matter of time
if you keep going at it you keep
hustling you keep pouring yourself into
it you keep being willing to try new
things eventually you're gonna hit it
that's the difference between somebody
who makes it and somebody who doesn't
believe those are watching let me know
what you think leave a comment below
tell me your story tell me your favorite
famous entrepreneur tell me how you're
struggling I want to hear a story below
you like this video give it a thumbs up
click on my face subscribe to the
channel see more videos like this thank
you so much I'll see you soon
you